as Ukraine's conflict with Russia and
the rebels it backs continues MEPS have
passed steps to help it deal with its
overshadowed economic and governance
crisis prolonging duty-free access to EU
markets for Ukrainian exports this after
the EU Ukraine Association agreement was
ratified last month and just before
parliamentary elections in Ukraine this
weekend which many MEPS hope will help
Ukraine begin to sort out pressing
domestic problems this defitely sends
the signal that Europe is still with
Ukraine but uh it is also important that
uh after the elections the ukrainians
really um tackle the corruption problems
that the the country
has there was concern in Parliament this
week at the effects of mos mayorum a two
we eu-wide police program this month to
round up illegal immigrants MOS mayorum
is Latin for way way of the elders and
as well as detaining migrants the idea
is to identify and disrupt organized
criminals seen as the root of the
problem but many MEPS felt it was
targeting the wrong
people MEPS also discussed human rights
infractions in three countries Russia
usbekistan and Mexico where 43 teaching
students are believed to be held by
drugs gangsters after their kidnap with
the help of local police in September we
have the same indignation that the
Mexican have at the moment and we ask
for protection protection for witness
protection for the victims and um family
members of those victims protection to
those that deliver Justice also MEPS
demanded us istan release all political
prisoners and stop all forms of torture
in prison they also condemned the
Russian authorities plan to close down
the independent human rights
organization Memorial which was the
winner of the European Parliament
sakarov prize for freedom of thought in